what's up everyone we're here with sunny
Jane from Sun genomics hi Alan thanks
for having me on the show I'm excited to
tell you more about the microbiome yeah
especially because we have all this
crazy stuff happening right now with
like the general data and privacy rights
and so like okay so if I do sign up for
Sun genomics who owns the data well of
course you do and we also have programs
of research to enable us to use
de-identified components of the data to
understand microbiomes
at a larger scale and provide benefit
then back to our product development and
eventually back to you again and and
we've used the same sort of security
protocols that government regulations
require we were also verified by the
human microbiome project a major project
run by the government to access their
data set and they've reviewed all our
protocols and security processes as well
good so you got a stamp of approval for
being able to like D identify the data
from the person and then be able to make
all the scientific advancements with the
data and then provide people with even
better collective and individual
analysis of microbiomes and probiotics
effects on them that's right and we
don't share that data today with anyone
else it's it's your data and it also is
a way for us to maintain your file
storage for you so that you don't have
to keep track of that information either
now what happens when I when I'm signing
up for some genomics do I need to talk
to a doctor before I do that what can I
do it at the same time maybe was that
look like they can't happen hand-in-hand
in fact many customers do talk to their
doctor about getting their gut tested
but you can just come directly to the
website and sign up and enroll as well
it's it's a over-the-counter product
that we're providing in the probiotic so
it's it's for general consumers and like
yeah it's probably a good idea to talk
to a physician about things but at the
same time a physician
is almost certainly not super deep into
understanding the bacteria that's going
on it's inside of you so because I mean
the simple fact that we need to take a
whole analysis of a team and understand
it versus just how can one even
understand it just by looking at you
right now it's so difficult to
understand yeah we have this technology
evolution that just occurred and it sort
of outpaced the medical advancement so
we're ready for the sequencing
technology to D be deployed to our gut
microbiomes instead of traditional
microbiology with swab identification
and characterization you can look at
things all at once just from the DNA and
that is just now being ratcheted into
back a little bit into that medical
community in building out some of the
more medically related impacts that the
microbiome actually has our focuses on
health and wellness though and getting
this kind of really amazing technology
in that in the hands of consumers as
fast as possible yeah that's a nuts
thing that's continuously happening as
technology's just advancing so quickly
that we didn't even know that we were
gonna have the capacity to understand
that and then all of a sudden we now
understand it better and we're like what
do we do with all this data how can we
figure it out now that's why this is
such a cool aspect of like you know what
are 40 years ago nobody was going oh
like one day we'll be able to understand
this and it just happened so much faster
than what we thought how quickly it
would happen now are there usually the
effects like in terms of feeling am I
gonna feel something different when I'm
taking your probiotics so some people do
without question in the first couple
weeks or months they will feel a
difference common things would be a
boost and mood a boost in energy
movements things that you might be
related to your GI system you might feel
some some changes there but it's not
always the case because they're not that
direct what they call phenotype
big Association but we can make that
really objective evidence back to you a
tree test so you can actually see what's
shifted from time point one to time
point two and then we're gonna track
that over time for you so if something
begins to go up like this we can flag
that for you and say you know what Ellen
the last three time points you were
baseline here and now it's three times
as high
have you changed something in your
lifestyle that would affect that microbe
mm-hmm and then is it okay to take some
genomics at the same time that I'm
taking other medication yeah we
integrate with whatever lifestyle our
customers are in and that in the context
of your health and wellness or your
physician is appropriate if if you're
taking sort of traditional
pharmaceuticals or something you would
want to talk to your doctor just like
you would any other supplement that you
take but we understand that there may be
some hesitations on certain medications
so you just work through those with your
medical professional and we're here to
help you in any way we can do we know
probiotics generally work fine with
other medications yeah a large number of
consumers take probiotics I'd say one in
five individuals in the United States
take a probiotic and most of us are on
some sort of medication at some level as
well so there's very little reason to
believe that these conflict with
anything because they're good microbes
for our gut but we don't know everything
in the context of medical practice so
that's why we guide you to your doctor
for that and then the retesting happens
every 90 days every 90 days you would
get a look into how your microbiome has
changed and so we think that's where the
most impactful changes will occur
there's always things happening inside
your microbiome and in sort of the my
new shows in small concentrations things
shifting
but when you want to see how how large
impacts have shifted we think every
three months is good yeah nice and then
of course just being in touch with Sun
genomic so you can get in touch with
laces levers there's some one that ends
up being like your account like manager
that you can talk to on a basis with
questions about what's going on yeah
we're all we're all available but we do
have a customer service to communicate
to and they kind of help triage
questions to the appropriate technical
suite individuals inside the company we
even have a board-certified pathologist
as our medical adviser and a and PhD
scientists as well onboard to help with
any real scientific questions as well
yeah that's great that's always great to
know that you can get the question a
funnel to the right people and that
they're readily available to be chat
with awesome so that was wrapping up
some of the QA about what Sun genomics
is doing and also with some of the
concerns that may come up from people
that want to get involved so thanks for
tuning in and catch us on another Sun
genomics video soon